[Music]
one of the big players in that world
someone i'm told moves more than a
million dollars worth of product daily
has agreed to meet me
well
kind of
okay we ready
so i'm currently in an empty room and in
front of a
table with nine pounds of all sorts of
different kinds of weed george i'm just
explaining what's happening to the
cameras because it feels really weird
that it's just me here so i'm just
explaining
george didn't want his actual voice
recorded george is actually out of view
he didn't feel comfortable being on
camera but he can hear me because of my
mic so we're using a voice changer that
alters it while he speaks if i were a
buyer i would come in here you'd have
all these bags out here with the
different samples they'd look at it
smell it no possibly try it smoke it
some smoking butters really just you
know based off the smell mainly the
and then they place orders is that it no
on the table is a variety of high-end
exotic indoor and outdoor weed
each pound bag costs between 2000 and
four thousand dollars
what's the largest order you've ever
received
[Music]
just one order that size is worth around
a million dollars
how much money is there to be paid in
illegal weed
uh endless
response i should really be talking
about this to someone like
a camera
i decide not to push it
so george you operate just a black
market business or do you operate also a
legal business
a license as well if you were to give me
a general sense of how
much money you make with your legal
versus your illegal business what would
you say
well technically i haven't made profit
off my legal business yet
wow
they try to kill you with fewest taxes
regulations
groups who jump through inspections
they go 10 times overboard than any
other business i wish for them to go
through the same regulations
so why operate a legal business if
you're not even making money out of that
for the love of it
why do i recite the pain or what is this
thing i like to sing
i'm rolling with the punches now and
just hanging in there so the
big business doesn't just
take all the original people out
you know you don't feel comfortable with
even being in the same room why do you
think there's so much uh
fear and mistrust
it's kind of
ingrained in that culture you can't
really trust people and that just comes
with money and greed and when people are
greedy
bad things happen
do you carry a gun
i
you really have no choice but to use it
[Music]
you